a suspected lone gunman identified as
Steven Craig paddock committed the
largest mass shooting in American
history last night killing at least 58
and injuring at least 515 this is still
developing those numbers are changing
within hours the hashtag thoughts and
prayers began trending on Twitter we'll
discuss why of all things thoughts and
prayers are controversial and under
attack then finally finally we will talk
to journalists Mary Lane about the
relation between the taking the football
movement and the right wing winning that
we're seeing all around us finally amber
at the Amanda Prestidge jacquimo and
Jacob arey joined the panel of
deplorable --zz to talk about John
Kasich sleeving the Republican Party
he's a Republican I didn't know that US
manufacturing soaring and UK schools
removing BC and AD dating so is not to
offend non-christians
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knoll Joe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's a rough way to start the week the
largest mass shooting in American
history I don't think that we need to go
into the details of what happened how it
happened who did this and who did that I
think plenty of other people are gonna
cover that I want to focus much more on
the response what the response says
about our culture what it says about how
we see ourselves obviously there are a
lot of questions how did he come to
possess fully automatic weapons those
have been practically outlawed for about
80 years although there are there are
ways to get them it's just very
difficult you know we're mental illness
signs ignored did he just snap all all
worth talking about but I am more
interested in how the cultural response
represents a conflict of visions between
the left and the right there was this
hashtag and started trending thoughts
and prayers but it wasn't earnestly
people saying we give you our thoughts
and prayers it was people mocking the
people who were offering thoughts and
prayers
the first crazy Twitter response was
from Hillary Clinton's surprise surprise
my dear old cousin Hillary Hillary said
the crowd fled at the sound of gunshots
imagine the deaths if the shooter had a
silencer which the NRA wants to make
easier to get cousin cousin Hillary what
come on girl what are you doing
obviously a silencer does not silence a
gun
you can't shoot off a two to three or a
five five to six it's still extremely
led it lowers it a few decibels but it's
still pretty loud so Hillary just
exemplifying how little the people who
want to take away all of our guns know
about guns whatsoever
she then tweeted and said and this is
what leads into the thoughts and prayers
she says our grief isn't enough we can
and must put politics aside stand up to
the NRA
and work together to try to stop this
from happening again it's just on the
Clintons the thing that defines them is
having absolutely no shame no sense of
shame whatsoever that the bodies aren't
even cool yet before Hillary Clinton
tries to score cheap points on the NRA
but but it consider this statement we
must put politics aside and stand up to
the NRA you just said to put politics
aside and now you're pushing gun control
you're you're offending one of the
largest most popular civil rights
lobbies in the entire country the NRA
which defends our Second Amendment right
to keep and bear arms that's Hillary
totally expected I mean you know perhaps
a little much
even for her but again the Clintons have
no sense of shame so who's surprised the
hashtag continued Caracalla Vera says
eff your thoughts and prayers they mean
nothing there is worthless as you are
now this woman I don't know who she is
describes herself as a marginally
talented writer unintentional comedian
and future corpse and that that last one
I mean she's making a sort of joke I
guess but it that actually does get to
the point because she's saying she's a
future corpse she's not a future
heavenly spirit she's not a future
reincarnated spirit or whatever she's a
corpse her view of the world as a
materialist view and so for her the
thoughts and prayers are meaningless in
people who offer them are jerks
from the Twitter account progress of a
kind and these all of these accounts
have a lot of followers after your
thoughts and prayers seriously there is
no more insincere meaningless comment in
American history it's a disgusting
cliché now I can think of a few
insincere ones we are the ones you you
we've been waiting for you can keep your
doctor if you like your doctor i they go
on and on and I did not have sex with
that woman or wait there are a lot of
empty statements that have been made in
recent political history but thoughts
and prayers perhaps this person really
does think that they're empty obviously
they're not empty but to someone with a
materialist view perhaps that's the case
then the Democratic senator from
Connecticut my former senator says quote
this must stop it is positively
infuriating that my colleagues in
Congress are so afraid of the gun
industry that they pretend there aren't
public policy responses to this epidemic
there are and the thoughts and prayers
of politicians are cruelly hollow if
they are paired with continued
legislative and difference it's time for
Congress to get off its ass and do
something there's a lot there's a lot of
stupidity in that statement obviously
the standing up to the NRA the NRA
represents the 100 million Americans who
have gone
the huge portion of this country that it
exhibits it's there that that uses its
Second Amendment right to keep and bear
arms and in a larger percentage of the
country that supports that right and
supports that important civil right but
for Congress to get off its ass that's
the statement that's going around and
for the thoughts and prayers to be
cruelly hollow why are they cruelly
hollow now I think the reason that they
think it's cruelly hollow is because
they don't believe in God if you believe
in God then your prayers are in Hollow
their prayers that's everybody for all
of history has prayed to God and they
don't they aren't hollow in traditional
religious observance if you think there
isn't a God then they are hollow they
actually are cruel because to those
people there is a public policy solution
that's what Chris Murphy says there's a
policy solution it's so easy let's just
take away all your guns
that's the subjects we take away all the
guns we get rid of the Second Amendment
we undo federalism and then it's so easy
well and then these events won't occur
these highly emotional disastrous events
won't occur now what they're presuming
is that something can be done there are
about 30,000 gun deaths a year in the
United States two-thirds of them are
suicide they're predominantly
middle-aged men who are killing
themselves is is that if we get rid of
the guns those guys aren't gonna kill
themselves there are there there's more
than one way to do it Dorothy Parker
wrote a poem about it what about mental
illness what about despair which law is
going to fix despair which public policy
solution which technocratic advancement
is going to stop people from viewing the
their culture in their life as
meaningless now if we could reduce these
gun deaths by tooth by getting rid of
the Second Amendment getting rid of the
federalist system coming state-to-state
down to town house to house and taking
everybody's guns what would that do to
other crime over that due to rape
burglary assault with those numbers
remain the same if only the bad guys had
guns but what would that mean for our
relationship to the government what
would that mean with about how we view
ourselves about how we view ourselves as
citizens as individuals with dignity I
have some thoughts on all of this but I
will save it for the final thought
because right now we have we have to
cover
something obviously much more important
than how we view ourselves as a nation
in this tragedy we have to talk about
these stupid football players getting on
their knee again this weekend we
actually have to cover it because in for
some reason this is a major news story
and it does say something about our
culture now I have tried to hit this
interview with Mary Lane who has an
interesting perspective and who thinks
that the football protests in Germany
played a large role in the right-wing
electoral winning in that country we
finally got the interview we had to do
it offline but we'll cut to it now and
hear her take now we finally have to
turn our attention to Mary Lane Mary is
an excellent journalist she's been with
wash of Wall Street Journal the New York
Times The Associated Press she's now
writing a book about Nazi art and
yesterday we tried to interview Mary
because she has an interesting
perspective from Germany on the relation
between football protests and national
politics and nationalism
apparently America isn't the first
country to deal with this obviously
there was some Zuckerberg in conspiracy
to keep us apart that would not allow us
to discuss this hot button social issue
but so what we've got you back today
Mary explain the entire situation to us
and it give us some context on how taken
need relates to politics yes I think as
many thing Americans thinks they
invented things but after this whole
policy for the sending of sports and the
fact that in Hub City was national pride
and something that's specific to our
community and even the word and FIFA
actually originated in Germany that's so
interesting so you saw this happen that
is really funny I guess those Germans
are so efficient I guess they just do
all these terrible things first so an
Tifa started their anti-fascist ìshe in
germany then now we have an Tifa and the
politicizing of sports started in
germany and now we have it here what
happened in Germany had it out of the
the sports issue come up yes
essentially this started in I mean a
little bit of background is that so in
2006 Germany got this chance to host the
World Cup and they were so excited
they're really into soccer it caught
propulsion but it also brought up this
problem because every other country
exposed to the World Cup has seen it is
this triumph of their national pride and
they're so like the ultimate dream of a
football player and any country suckling
is to sing the national anthem for the
World Cup on their own soil and this was
never a problem before but in Germany
the national anthem since World War Two
was so associated with Nazis chill and
uber alles right yeah exactly so after
World when they came up with the joy
under father's song and then afterwards
who they decided to keep the song but
used a third verse which is about unity
and freedom and justice which sounds
anodyne but the fact that they kept the
same tune was like really awkward and
and they took the at least they took out
the verse about just killing everybody
in the world especially the Jews which
is really good that's a lyrical
improvement but a big problem in 2006
was in every other country a politician
would have said like I'm so proud to be
South African and the World Cup is in
South Africa in Germany even on going
bambor who has been the Chancellor for
12 years to this day will never be
caught dead sings and I'm proud to be
German
and even the phrase like so I've been in
Germany nine and a half years I could
technically become her but she would
never say if gerbil say I get a German
passport I would never say no and I'd
have to give up my American one by B
whole German mm-hmm you would never
linguistic would say in German I had
become German he's been doing abroad
well this raises an interesting point
about American exceptionalism too
one can become an American because the
country was settled by my dear ancestors
my religious extremist ancestors who
came from the UK through Latin to
America then there came the IRA the
scots-irish the Irish there were
American Indians who integrated the
first people we saw were Samoset and and
what's the other guys named Squanto and
obviously there were black slaves who
came over
so it's a country that doesn't really
have an ethnic identity per se whereas
Germany when you think of a German you
get an image in your mind when you think
of a Frenchman you get a much more
pathetic image in your mind and so on
and so forth in 2010 because so and this
is what we get to Antipa I'm suspicious
must a country pop it is that this
Turkish in Germany in Berlin and in an
area where Turkey would turn the
backgrounds and annoying students and
tourists have been together since the
nineteen fifties they say God got a
twenty two meters so what does that like
sixty foot flag completely unfamiliar
with the metric system but sure I'll
take you back for it 60 foot sure so
they put it over like all four stories
in their house it's German flag and they
were they were they've been from Lebanon
and they had become German Sisson and
they were so proud right any got torn it
became his national show sorry because
they had people were tearing it down but
it wasn't Nazis or far-right people turn
it down it wasn't Eva it was the left
the left was upset that the immigrants
were grateful toward the country that
had taken them in so essentially that's
what led overs because you know people
saw this bird on two thousand ten and
that's when the far-right birdy
and obviously in teeth and Germany
started blooming but then in 2013 the
off day the far-right party only got
four point seven percent of the vote and
everyone was like cuz you have to get
five percent to do parliamentary
representation but aa date was like hey
like we're a really new party and we got
4.5% with no funding like watch out guys
because 2017 is coming from the whole
the world conference 2014 and then
Germany pummeled Brazil 71 in in Brazil
was the whole country and you know no
one there were no like foul play going
on it was just like Germany was the
better team and normally you would be
look so excited to be being the home
country I mean maybe bummed out but
Raziel was bummed out but they weren't
saying like oh you're racist or
something and besides they were
colonized by the Portuguese anyway
you know hey Germans in the bar weren't
depressed they were like like they
wanted to win but they were like like
like once I got to about 4 1 they were
like oh my god oh my god like this
giddiness ml is the worst colonization
that we've engaged in hundreds of years
you know person I was like you know and
it and like anecdotal evidence it's not
their evidence but the plural of
anecdote is data it is true and then the
next day I go in the newspapers Germany
has a very wide newspaper so every major
cities newspaper is widely disturb it
and every single one was like ashamed of
the fact that the Western self
flagellation is endlessly stunning it
never ceases to amaze me but now if this
is all happening there if politics is
downstream of culture we see this
happening in Germany ten years later
eleven years later what can we look
forward to in the United States there's
a lot of good news but there's also some
you know interesting if you look say
yeah down the road consequences of
culture so basically the establishment
parties that didn't want to take a side
on either of anthem problems they had
their worst and that meant Vic the
miracles party is still raining she's
gonna be having 16 years of consecutive
power now but she has to team up with
these kind of smaller parties the FDP
and the greens what was good for America
out of that is that Russia Hawks and
they're gonna be less oppositional to
the idea of spending money on NATO and
that is really good news for America
because they are he businesses and they
are for less regulation but the problem
is is that since so many people are
divided there might be so much internal
gridlock getting into these great
benefits for America may not have
Mary thank you so much for being here
that's a really interesting perspective
and nobody's talking about it but it's
pretty scary to think about it is pretty
strange the analogy to when you think
about the crazy leftist culture the
lefties ripping down symbols of national
pride and the the push rightward that
then the culture engages in and how
perhaps internal gridlock makes it
difficult to do anything something to
watch out for I guess it's just things
that are coming up in the United States
maybe it won't take as long as Germany
did okay now it is time to move to our
panel of deplorable and do we have an
excellent one today we have from The
Daily wire Amanda presto Giacomo also
from The Daily wire we have Jacob berry
and from the Daily Caller we have amber
Athey now our first question is going to
you Amanda I don't want to harp on this
too much but we were talking about
political gridlock we're talking about
Hillary Clinton moving in on this issue
immediately movie and trying to
politicize this tragedy immediately
president Trump is not exactly an
orthodox political player could we see
any gun control coming out of this White
House I mean yes he's not politically
worth attacks in any way but the thing
is is that the NRA back President Trump
really early on and they poured millions
of dollars into his campaign this is
like in the primary and they're still
pushing out a lot of ads for President
Trump against the protests against him
etc so sure I never know what President
Trump is going to do I know there are a
lot of calls on the left for crackdowns
on this they're going to exploit the
heck out of this tragedy but the NRA has
really been there for President Trump so
it would be pretty surprising to me if
he does kind of crackdown on this let's
hope and you know it is true that he's
not an orthodox political player but
he's been pretty good and in some ways
more conservative than I think many of
the ostensibly more conservative
candidates would have been in office all
right enough about this tragedy sorry
your last point Amanda oh yes I mean doc
O'Connor me for a loop that's the only
reason why I'm like hold some recreation
I thought he was gonna use that at least
to get like funding
but that didn't happen he just kind of
tosses the Congress so I have a little
hesitation but it wouldn't really make
sense for him to go at this gun control
hope springs eternal in the human breast
okay on 2 News John Kasich announced
that he might leave the Republican Party
he was sucking up to Jake Tapper and
explained quote if the party can't be
fixed Jake then I'm not going to be able
to support the party period that's the
end of it
Amanda this of course raises one
question John Kasich is a Republican
[Laughter]
learning this for the first time that
interview he was talking about how you
know basically how trumpism has taking
over the Republican Party and you know
we're anti-immigrant now oh when I
clutch my pearls the thing is during the
primary John Kasich stayed in the race
to basically you know essentially give
Donald Trump that nomination
he'll stated when there was no path what
was that he killed Cruz he stayed in so
long he totally destroyed Cruz's chances
100% he basically gave President Trump
the nomination so this is it's all about
John Kasich I don't believe anything he
says he clutches his pearls when he
knows that bodes well with his Ohio
constituents but he doesn't really care
if he did care about this he window
basically clinched the nomination for
president Trump during the primary punch
anartha amber this seems to me like a
classic example of I'm a conservative
but I'm not that kind of a conservative
ISM which is very prevalent I've noticed
it on campuses I've noticed it in polite
conversation people say well I'm a
conservative but I don't support
president Trump please like New York
Times please please like me how
prevalent is this phenomenon on the
right
well definitely prevalent enough to pose
a problem to President Trump as we saw
with the repeal and replace with
Obamacare it really only took three or
four of those so-called not that kind of
conservatives to kill the repeal and
replace effort and then when you look at
the media it's the same exact thing
you'll have former bush staffers getting
their cushy gigs at MSNBC and CNN where
all they have to do is trash Trump and
they get you know their little
six-figure salary after they got out of
the Bush administration so then you have
not only the
liberals posing a media challenge to
Trump but also these so-called
Republicans including John Kasich who
are just trying to you know oppose
anything Trump doesn't doesn't matter
what it is just so that they can be
accepted by the mainstream media yeah
there's a woman named Anna Navarro who
goes she says that she's a Republican
strategist that's just the term by the
way if you don't do anything but you
want to black yeah I mean she where she
has worked been associated with these
more left-wing campaigns John Huntsman
John McCain that sort of thing actually
surrounded by the man who's advising
John Weaver as well but you know someone
like Anna Navarro it seems like her only
job is to attack Republicans well
nominally being a Republican Jacob is
there any place for these squishy the
liberal moderates in the Republican
Party yes it's called a primary my wife
described John Kasich the best during
the 2016 GOP primaries she said he's the
guy who showed up to the party uninvited
and then refused to leave that's exactly
John Kasich and for him to just go on
this virtue signaling and you look I am
NOT Trump's biggest fan I think he's
maybe you and John Nolte are tied but
but but seriously John Kasich and people
like Anna Navarro they make me ashamed
of being an entre at vaq it you know
it's it's kind of like oh guys just sit
down and shut up they do they make you
want to do you don't want to defend
Trump because of Trump you want to
defend it because his critics are so
shrieky and frustrating and they make us
who are against Trump from a
conservative angle think oh maybe we
should back Trump right absolutely right
in other news us manufacturing activity
has hit a 13-year high Ithaca fake
construction spending is up Reuters is
reporting that in September there is
strong gains in new orders raw material
prices and points to the underlying
strength in the economy even as
hurricane Harvey and
irma are expected to dent growth in the
third quarter so amber is this the
winning that trump promised us are you
sick and tired of winning definitely not
sick and tired of winning you'll never
get sick and tired of it
but it definitely does sound like
winning in terms of what Trump
campaigned on and what a lot of his
supporters were hoping for when they
voted for him as we know a lot of Trump
supporters were those blue collar Blue
Dog Democrats who previously voted for
Barack Obama and then switched to vote
for Trump because they were hoping that
he was able to bring manufacturing jobs
back to the United States so this is you
know a really good win for those people
who said maybe we don't love Trump's
personality but we really like the fact
that he's sort of campaigning for this
forgotten man in middle America yeah for
this forgotten man you know between Los
Angeles and New York forgotten subject
called the economy absolutely what about
the trans bathrooms that we all care
about okay we have to keep talking about
this but unfortunately you can't watch
if you are not a subscriber to daily
wire.com we have to say goodbye to you
on Facebook and YouTube if you are a
subscriber thank you thank you for
supporting this it keeps the lights on
it keeps my cup full of coffe fa so if
you're not what you have to do is right
now go to daily wired.com you'll pay $10
a month $100 a year what do you get you
get no ads on the website you'll get me
you'll get the panel of deplorable you
get the under Clavin show you'll get the
Ben Shapiro show I could go on but I
know I'm boring you forget all that you
get this you get the leftist tears
tumblr this is the most coveted this is
the most coveted item on the market
today it is the perfect vessel for
leftist tears obviously they pour out
the National Football League has filled
up our entire supply we have to order
more so keep ordering them we'll keep
shipping you can have those leftist
tears hot or cold always salty and
delicious go over there right now daily
wire calm we'll be right back
Jakub some are saying that the reason
that the manufacturing growth has surged
is because of these hurricanes is a
response to the Hurricanes is that true
or the Hurricanes playing a role or are
they just trying to take away the White
House's credit I think they're trying to
take away the White House's credit
honestly and of course you'll always see
an uptick in manufacturing after some
sort of disaster and a war is really
good for manufacturing but in all
honesty I think that this is just an
attempt to take credit away from Trump's
economic policies which you you have to
admit are are doing some good for our
economic situation yeah I'm almost sick
and tired of winning but enough about
that let's talk about ridiculous things
that don't really seem to matter in
little trivialities on campuses schools
across the UK are doing away with the
terms BC and AD in favor of BCE before
the Common Era and seee Common Era to
denote precisely the same thing same
dates the Archbishop of Canterbury has
blasted the Musa is shameful and
reporting has made it clear that Muslim
and Jewish leaders quote were also
mystified saying that they were not
offended by the familiar terms the
familiar terms meaning on O Domini the
year of our Lord now this was happening
even when I was in high school and this
gets to the heart of my theory of
leftism which is that leftists want the
form of the thing but they they don't
want the essence of it so they want the
form of Western civilization they
literally want its mode of dating itself
but they don't want the heart of it
which is Christianity on O Domini the
Year Zero denotes the the year that a
man named Jesus Christ was born
so does this matter a man is it just a
minor thing a couple of letters no big
deal it's no big deal right yeah so this
is this is kind of what the left does I
mean they they always push these about
just kind of reminds me of like when
there's a monument of the Ten
Commandments and nobody complains about
except some random liberal activist
group you know six dates away and then
they take it down I mean they want to
disassemble any
assemblance or any anything resembling
judeo-christian values that basically
built Western civilization they want it
gone and as we saw just recently with
the the whole debate over civil war
monuments it's always there's it's
always gonna go way too far I mean what
they were talking about taking down
statues of robert e lee and then two
days later an asian guy from ESPN was
losing gigs i mean which is ridiculous
and it's gonna keep on going mm-hmm
amber nobody in the Jewish or Muslim
communities in the UK seems to be
offended by the terms with which we date
our civilization is anybody actually
offended by this who is offended by this
or is this another classic example of
people pretending to be offended on
other people's behalf yeah I think most
of it is just classic virtru signaling
from as amanda said these sort of small
fringe liberal groups and i know this is
true because these groups will attack
people who are supposed to be offended
but aren't offended a great example this
when i was in college
someone actually made a sandwich joke
about women on a on facebook and i
thought it was hilarious i laughed at it
no you don't have to tell me somebody
accused me of having internalized
misogyny because i laughed at the joke
so it's all about these people because
they're like oh well how dare you for
not being so happy that i'm offended for
you can't you see how good of a person
i'm being it's true and it's actually
harder for us men by the way because we
eat the sandwiches and then further
internalize the massage and it's a
vicious cycle jacob what about the
separation of church and state come on
man aren't we supposed to keep church
and state separate freedom of religion
is it really right for us to be dating
our calendars by the name of Jesus well
if it wasn't for Christians or the
church there would be no calendar the
Julian calendar was off I think
something by three weeks which is what
they had before the Gregorian calendar
so you're welcome
but you know it's very kind of it yeah
but I just think that it's it's just
virtue signaling it's nothing but
showboating I don't personally you
should see some of the alternative
calendars they've been suggesting and
BCE and C is just kind of the easiest
ones but they've been suggesting ones
where they start marking the years by
10,000 so this year would actually be
1217 I mean they're just they're just
are twelve thousand seventeen I mean
they're just ridiculous yeah and you
have to date it by Lord Xenu and there
are a lot of competing metrics and you
you bring up another good point so you
bring up the point that without
Christian Church we wouldn't have this
calendar exactly we also wouldn't have
separation of church and state
we also crisis render unto Caesar that
which is Caesars that to God that which
is God's and obviously our civilization
is Christian it's been formed by
Christianity our country is Christian it
was formed by Christian ideals of
natural law natural rights so without
that we simply wouldn't we wouldn't have
anything to be arguing about in the
first place
okay panel get out of here you it's been
very fun having you a man amber Athey
Amanda presto Giacomo and Jacob berry
now it is time to put on my smart
glasses for the final thought
Ben had a good piece up on Daly wire
today called where does evil come from
in it he describes psychologist Roy
Baumeister's four categories of evil
instrumentality threatened egotism
idealism and sadism and he adds his own
mental illness
what does evil look like what form does
evil take how does evil express itself
in the mind are important psychological
questions that emotionally manipulative
Democrat politicians willfully ignore
when they capitalize on human tragedy to
push largely unconnected policy agendas
but it's a good question - where does
evil come from that question is not
ultimately a psychological problem it's
a philosophical problem and the answer
to that question lies at the heart of
the political debates that began seconds
after the news of the Las Vegas tragedy
were reported for utopians on the left
evil comes from bad public policy tweak
a few laws here give the government some
more power there and we'll be right back
in Paradise they say imagine all the
people you may say I'm a dreamer but I'm
not the only one the rest of us know
that this is nonsense that the
imagination of man's heart is evil from
his youth we are fallen and banished
from earthly paradise and wherever there
are men there will be evil no government
policy or agency can redeem mankind but
idealists persist in their delusion
because it's far nicer to delude
ourselves into thinking that a law can
eradicate all evil than it is to face
the grotesqueries that we glimpse in the
mirror on that
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
nul show come back next time we'll do it
all again
[Music]
[Music]